the proof of the violence of this crash
is just how little wreckage there is
left to see
only fragments of china eastern flight
5735
carrying 132 people remain
the plane was atomized these tiny pieces
are a terrifying end but they are clues
too
it is hard to piece together this puzzle
in the middle of these remote southern
mountains
but along with the experts an army of
volunteers is here too
when people here uh always heard the sad
news um we just think the life's the
most important thing we just want to
help the screen team
we hope we will find survivors and i
believe they will find finally find the
fact what happened
the volunteers have their work cut out
there this is a makeshift search and
rescue center in a local village near
the crash site but we arrived here to
the terrible news that there are no
survivors from that plane crash instead
what these volunteers are going to do is
go to that mountain find every last
scrap of metal that they can these are
tiny scraps from that huge huge crash
and try and piece together what happened
the video you're about to see captured
by a cctv camera is distressing
it appears to show a jet noise diving
fast into the ground
only minutes before they have been
cruising normally
that rapid uncontrolled descent is
incredibly unlikely in a modern
passenger jet and requires explanation
i don't like to speculate but the sort
of areas the investigators will be
looking at will be sabotage hijack or
suicide
along with structural breakup of the
aircraft at the tail because it's the
tail which controls the aircraft up or
down they'll exclude the possibility of
a bomb
because the bomb will be
indicated by the aircraft breaking up in
the air which again doesn't suggest took
place
the families of the 132 people on board
have now all been notified
not far from the crash site locals
gathered to light candles in a small
buddhist ceremony they said it was to
help the souls of the victims find peace
but their families will need answers too
tom cheshire sky news near wujo city
south china